it is Walt I'm Donald Trump says the
construction of the Mexican border wall
will begin immediately he signed an
executive order regarding immigration
here is lion Shawn as I'm calling him
Donald Trump's press secretary Sean
Spicer take a look at the big
announcement the first order is the
border security and immigration
enforcement improvements it addresses
long overdue border security issues and
it's the first order order of in that
will be to build a large large physical
barrier on the southern border building
this barriers more than just a campaign
promise or a common-sense first step to
really securing our porous border if
anything it's not common sense but I'll
get to that a little bit later of course
no details provided about the length of
the wall or the cost of the wall not at
all surprising now remember Mexico will
pay for the wall right well no the new
plan is that US taxpayers will be paying
for the wall and then somehow Trump's
going to negotiate with Mexico that they
will pay for the wall how he doesn't
provide the details what we do know is
that the Mexican President Nieto says he
is not going to pay for the wall Mexico
will not pay for the wall we know that
Donald Trump tweeted this morning about
the upcoming meeting with Donald Trump
that if they're not going to pay for it
if Mexico is not going to pay for the
wall then we might as well cancel that
meeting and it is really not looking
like Mexico is going to pay for the wall
Trump also planning to cancel catch and
release he wants those caught at the
border to be detained at taxpayer
expense and you know who makes a ton of
money by detaining undocumented
immigrants until they're deported big
banks that invest in prisons with
contracts to detain people for pre
deportation holding no surprise about
the plutocracy there Trump also signed
another order to take federal grant
money away from so-called sanctuary
cities totally ludicrous totally
authoritarian many mayors have already
said yet we're just not going to do it
and then reminder the wall makes no
sense right we actually don't need the
wall nor more anti-immigration measures
the wall won't stop people as I've told
you because of tunnels
ladders for physical crossings but more
importantly a ton of undocumented
immigration is from people overstaying
visas are people flying in and then just
not leaving the country and also and
this is the amazing thing that nobody
seems to get on the right pad we're at a
net loss with regard to undocumented
immigration from Mexico number one
undocumented immigration from Mexico
continues to decline it's at a 40-year
low and there are bigger outflows to
Mexico than inflows from Mexico over the
last 40 years this is when we least
needed to do anything additional well I
mean regardless of whether it makes
sense or whether it'll be effective I
mean Donald Trump has promised to build
this wall from day one yeah one in part
by by reaching out to the more
nationalistic in racist factions of the
Republican Party tour so regardless of
whether or not it's going to be
effective and how costly it's going to
be of course it's going to go through
with it right because he's going to get
things done again here's a graph as I
mentioned there's never been a time in
the last 40 years we're spending money
on a wall was less necessary here is us
apprehensions of undocumented immigrants
by nationality the idea that immigrants
commit tons of crime is wrong we know
that border cities with large amounts of
undocumented Mexican immigrants like San
Diego and El Paso have some of the
lowest crime rates in the country
generally speaking there's no link at
all between immigration and unemployment
of native-born workers undocumented
immigrants have a big positive effect on
the economy is the reality most of the
money that undocumented immigrants make
is spent in the US some goes back to
their native countries but most doesn't
and number two undocumented immigrants
are paying into programs that they'll
never use which will be really important
as baby boomers continue to retire this
doesn't defend law-breaking but this is
to make the point that not only is the
wall not a solution it is also the least
necessary thing that we've seen in
decades with regard to immigration what
will the Trump is do if Trump builds the
wall or a partial wall or some fencing
and says he did it and made America
great again yet jobs continue to
disappear who will they blame I don't
really know the answer